هي بنت الشهيده ديك هي بنت الشهيده ام
الزهري الصغيره هي هذ
[موسيقى]
بنتان الله
يرحمهم راحوا اخواننا
واحد اخواننا راحوا سنتنا راحوا وختوا
عمتوا عمده
راحوا يرح الله يرحمهم والله راحوا
الله يجمعنا فيهم شهداء يا رب الله يسمعنا
فيهم
شهداء تقبل شهداء يا
ارد الحمد
للهد الاعلى ان شاء الله الفردوس الاعلى
يا
[موسيقى]
ربيل
الجواز
ال النا فيهم ان شاء الله انت الج اليهود
يا رب هدول اللي اشتار الوطن والله
اشتراهم وبعناهم لربنا بعناهم لربنا دول
يا رب يا الله تتقبل يوم الجمعه يا رب
بعناهم يا رب ربح
البيع الله اكبر الله
اكبر احنا ال عفان وال شحاده لن نتقبل
التعازي بل نتقبل التهاني والتبريكات الله
اكبر ولله الحمد الله اكبر جزك الله خيرا
يا ابانا انت ابونا كلنا ابو الشهداء
ابونا كلنا الحمد لله الله يرحم الله
يجعلك في